we've got a fun game for you guys okay
speed round it's called game of phones
now tell me which of your co-stars this
applies to okay what did you text first
about what happens to you in your final
episode him
amazing I don't think I text anybody
yeah I didn't
it would have been kid but kid didn't
read the episodes until the actual cast
readers Natalie Emmanuel no one no one
nobody don't tell anybody if anyone I
would have texted him okay just leave me
alone
which of your co-stars takes the best
selfies kids okay
well it's gotta be so for maze Sophie
how's miss amazing amazing William knows
exactly what I was gonna say the
funniest means in the group chat Oh
Alfie Alfie Allen yes converse is quite
yeah he's pretty good selfie sent a
really good hit the other day I'm not
talking about it he's saying some quite
for anyone sometimes do I thank you for
something that's gonna be Maisie right
yeah as in actually funny amazing my mom
oh wait my wife it wouldn't be someone
in the car be my wife probably well it
wouldn't be anyone from Game of Thrones
a lawyer I think Nikolaj coster-waldau
Jacob Anderson half thought I would film
Rory but he never answers his phone may
be used in comfort I might give you [ __ ]
for bail money money
yeah probably kit no sorry mate I'm just
cool others go up in there in a country
house sorry which emoji would your
character be not really nervy looking
emoji that has like a little bit of
sweat coming down there cuz he's so edgy
imma be there woman holding the baby oh
yeah hungry pretty handy for that is
there a raven emoji yeah sure that one
alright just a smile a bald round face
monkey or a spider okay spider
we have emojis we have twitter emojis
now just put the name in I'm 300 years
old I don't know you got me on Twitter
yeah sure Liam yeah yeah don't stick
obviously the bug my would be that one
with the line for a face you know it's
like it's just like yeah that's one of
my favourite little life I would be a
habit ah nice
[Music]